the man the myth the legend it's
official John Legend is People
magazine's 2019
sexiest man alive the announcement was
made during Tuesday night's episode of
The Voice with 2017 sexiest man alive
Blake Shelton providing the big reveal
it's literally shocking the
singer/songwriter took to Instagram to
share this hilarious throwback comparing
himself to last year's sexiest man alive
Audra Salva quote 1995 John would be
very perplexed to be following 2018
Idris Elba as sexiest man alive he'll
2019 John is about as equally perplexed
but thank you people for finding me sexy
I'll take it but the e got winner is of
course no stranger to awards I never
dreamed that I would be here winning an
Emmy and being in that rare group of
people that have won all four of these
major Academy Awards during the show
legend also took a moment to thank his
wife Chrissy Teigen
what is your wife Chrissy Teigen think
of this she's proud of me you know she
makes fun of me almost all the time but
she hasn't even been snarky about this
like she's like legit proud of me as
always the Twitter Queen herself
immediately brought the laughs tweeting
quote hashtag eat got PS MA
we have plenty of room in the house for
all the trophies so we make room even
leading up to the big announcement the
model and host said quote I have big
news and it's killing me I can't say it
and it's not a baby
to which she of course shared later
quote my secret is out I have fulfilled
my dream of having boned People's
Sexiest Man Alive in honor Teigen also
posted this hilarious video of their
daughter Luna reacting to the news Luna
are you so happy daddy's the sexiest man
alive
Oh
[Music]